je voudrais vous livrer une idée toute
simple en espérant vous pourrez
appliquer dès demain matin
l'idée est simple nous sommes des êtres
sociaux
nous ne sommes pas des ermites et quel
que soit le groupe dans lequel nous
entrons nous allons rapidement
comprendre les bons comportements qui
vont nous valoir un certain nombre de
bénéfices et gratifications appartenance
reconnaissants nous n'y échappons pas ça
commence tout petit nos parents nous
apprennent que crayonné les murs en
rouge
pas génial se laver les dents c'est
mieux a évidemment ça c'est pour tout le
monde mais on commence à spécifier des
familles je suis né dans une famille où
tout le monde est ingénieur le père la
mère le grand-père la grand mère j'ai
rapidement compris que le bon
comportement serait que vont il faisait
des maths
ce serait bien et qu'une bonne note en
masse à l phase iii mauvaise note en
sciences nat et que annuel d'une
mobylette
voilà le contrat invisible est déjà
passée alors son rapport avec la
confiance tout simplement parce que
c'est le décor dans lequel on se
comprend tout devient prévisible
en fait j'ai trouvé le contrat invisible
non pas à cause des maths mais parce que
je suis rentré dans une grande société
de conseil et je me suis amusé à
regarder comment les clients parler de
nous et il n'était pas tellement
sensible à la méthodologie con qu'on
utilisait entre différentes cabinet mais
beaucoup plus hostile et au comportement
que nous avions et quelque part c'est à
partir de ça que j'ai reconstitué cette
idée de contrat un vip renault trois
sociétés on va les appeler à b et c pour
le gêner personne
dans cette société de conseil a bien on
apprend que le bon comportement c'est
d'abord un comportement de prestige
social c'est à dire je me comporte non
seulement comme un excellent
professionnel mais je me comporte en
portant urbain
or be le drapeau de la société et en lui
donnant un modèle aristocratie au fond
je rends dans ces sociétés et on me dit
tu es un aristocrate et tu resteras 1h
et je dois me comporter comme tels voilà
l'essence dans la société b -
d'aristocratie le sujet c'est de montrer
qu'on est intellectuellement brillant
donc le contrat invisible il dit soit le
plus brillant possible conceptuellement
et ton n'associez qui est en train de te
regarder va te promouvoir vers l'eau
donc le client dans un cas voir
quelqu'un qui fait assaut de prestige
social dans l'autre cas c'est surtout ce
qui est très important c'est de montrer
une grande force intellectuelle
voilà deux contres invisibles différents
imaginons qu'on réunit ces deux sociétés
ne marche pas alors fort de sa fille
mais est-ce que seuls les consultants
des contrats invisible et non je suis
rentré petit à petit dans l'idée de on
va chercher on regarde dans une société
observé ça tous les jours regarder comme
les comportements sont relativement
mimétique et qu'on n'en sort pas
beaucoup finalement alors les premiers
exemples que j'ai vu ces grandes
sociétés françaises qui sont de service
public
imaginez que vous soyez un distributeur
d'électricité dont je t'ai un nom et
vous rentrez dans cette société c'est le
service public donc mon comportement
c'est très simple je dois me comporter
comme quelqu'un qui va avoir à toujours
un acte héroïque pour apporter
l'électricité à tous les français et en
échange de quoi je vis un peu dans une
cote supérieure
tout va bien à fournir les qui livre le
contrat c'est un équilibre entre deux
choses mais imaginons un beau matin
qu'on dise non mais ça c'est fini il va
falloir faire de la productivité alors à
ce moment-là les cent supérieur
disparaît le contre invisible est cassé
prenons un autre exemple
souvenez-vous le e-business des années
2000 le contraint visite mettait je pars
je vais vers l' aventure comme des
chercheurs d'or et le contrat visible et
très simple et 10 aventure tous les
jours adrénaline tous les jours voilà
c'est donc la grande excitation tous les
jours et imaginez un beau matin que un
banquier arrive en écouter c'est sympa
votre truc mais maintenant le fera
gagner de l'argent donc je pense
manager et je vais lui dire et le
manager harry mais d'écouter les amis
maintenant à faire des budgets vous êtes
priés d'arriver alors si possible de
mettre une cravate mais je serai pas
encore trop regardants là dessus et on
l'a et le contrat visible et termine
donc on a cassé le contrat invisible et
du coup l'existence même de la société
est en jeu
alors ce qui est important c'est que
fait le point important c'est que il
suffit pas d'être intelligent en
regardant encontre invisible les autres
face à une transformation un
entrepreneur a le risque de devoir
toucher le contrat vite de façon forte
ou très forte donc dans toute
transformation un dirigeant va regarder
et il ne fera pas comme ça
si le contrat y vivent et heurté et donc
ce qui est extrêmement important c'est
qu'il le comprenne
mais en réalité quand le dirigeant a
compris le contrat bible n'a pas fait
grand chose parce que s'ils le comprends
ça n'a pas beaucoup évolué ce qui est
important c'est de faire émerger le
contrat est visible en disant voilà je
vous avais compris qui vous êtes vous
même et dans cette société
ou peut-être que naguère on avait le
service public bah oui mais on peut plus
faire comme ça alors soit on dit que on
va revenir au passé quasiment impossible
soit on constate tous ensemble qu'il ya
un bout de bonheur qui avait dans cette
boîte un but contre un invisible qui
était notre bonheur qui était notre
façon d'être
c'était le décor où on se comprend qu'il
va falloir changer et comme on ne change
jamais une société sans que les gens
aient envie de changer il faut
effectivement l'idée c'est donc de faire
travailler ce contrat vim alors ainsi
fut fait c'est à dire de dire maintenant
les outils digitaux nous permettent de
comprendre ça et grâce à des outils
digitaux on est capable de faire en
sorte que 10000 personnes comprennent
leur contrat jb dix mille personnes se
disent ok il ya un petit bout de ça
qu'il va falloir changer parce que c'est
ça qui est c'est ça qui est essentiel
prenons un autre exemple fusion à chaque
fois vous fusionne les deux entreprises
vous n'êtes absolument sûr et certain de
détruire deux contres invisible 1
société industrielle à qui fusionne avec
sociétés industrielles b avec à
l'intérieur de ces deux sociétés
industrielles des ingénieurs qui se
connaissent parfaitement parce qu'ils
étaient sur les bancs des mêmes écoles
vous imaginez les noms donc ces gens se
comprennent y sont unis par des mêmes
rempart des mêmes quote part des mêmes
langages et pourtant vingt ans après les
uns sont société à l'autre société dans
la société un ont dit le contraire lips
et dit toute décision doit être les
ensembles dire tout ce que tout ce qui
ce fait cet ensemble quand on quand on
prend une décision
ça doit être ensemble et d'ailleurs ils
le savent très bien parce que quand tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord on
recommence la décision prise le mar bis
une bonne base de discussion si tout le
monde n'est pas la corde dans la société
bc le contraire société b s'est défait
des analyses des chiffres des cartes est
au pouvoir et donc quand on a pris des
sillons l'appliquent à cct a quand après
des sillons vérifie que tout le monde
est d'accord
vous mélangez les deux sociétés et vous
avez la situation suivante où on a dit
dans la société à qu'on allait acheter
une moquette bleue pour changer le seul
tapis de sol et on s'aperçoit que la
semaine d'après y'a rien alors cela
sociétés mais comprendre avait pris une
décision n'est pas prise et audible non
on n'a pas vraiment prise
il faut laisser une seconde chance à la
décision dans la société a dans la
société dans l'autre société
c'est juste c'est juste tout à fait
impossible donc observer ce que vous
voyez dans votre dans votre propre
entreprise mais mettons toute
organisation
eh bien voyez qui est un contre
invisible qui nous lie l heure de la
transformation
il va falloir regarder ce contrat valide
parce que nous changerons pas le monde
et nous changeons pas les sociétés sans
que les gens aient pris conscience de la
nécessité de changer par en acceptant
qu'ils invitent bonheur perdu sentons
apple l'entreprise et regardons est-ce
que ce ce schéma est applicable à plus
grande échelle
y at il un contre-un vivent dans un pays
amusons nous apprendre la france et
amérique la france dit égalité
fraternité liberté égalité fraternité
c'est écrit n'est ce pas monsieur le
maire à tous les frontons des mairies
les américains disent pas le contraire
si vous regardez ce qu'il ya dans l'eure
dugit ont dit exactement la même chose
le vrai contraint visible chez les
français c'est le bon français doit se
comporter pour défendre d'abord
l'égalité
peu importe sa coloration politique le
bon français descendre dans la rue quand
l'égalité menacée donc si on veut
arrêter une loi il faut dire qu'elle
n'est pas égalitaire
elle n'est pas juste et ça c'est notre
contrat invisible français qui fait
qu'en dans toute transformation
il ya ce frein qui va dire à attention
c'est pas juste donc on va donc ça
demande un peu d'habileté prenons
l'amérique
liberté égalité fraternité mais
fondamentalement c'est la liberté qui va
compter et particulièrement la liberté
de commerce qui est le faux le
fondamental américains la liberté
commerce donc si je vais me fâcher je
descends dans la rue en dix ans il n'y a
pas de liberté obamacare les américains
descendre dans la rue en disant c'est
une atteinte à la liberté est ce que
vous imaginez une seconde que les
français descendent dans la rue en
verrons la sécurité sociale c'est une
atteinte à la liberté
on est vraiment dans des mondes
complètement a pas un
donc l'idée c'est simplement nous sommes
tous le jouet d'un contrat que nous
passons pas ce que nous voudrons
d'entrer dans le groupe auquel on
appartient et que on n'y échappe pas
tout à fait c'est ça et vous pouvez
l'observer absolument tous les jours
donc je vous laisse avec cette idée là
et je vous dis monsieur le maire deviner
quelles contraintes cible issy les
moulineaux merci
[Applaudissements]